one of the most
um sort of mask off moments literally
and metaphorically through the pandemic
about the American right wing has been
the viciousness with which the right has
attacked medical professionals in
general around the pandemic but in
particular the way Dr Anthony fauci has
been attacked not only in terms of
physical threat to the point where he
needs full-time security but attacked in
terms of his motives attacked through
conspiracies and on and on and on and
one of the main uh elected officials who
has been attacking Dr fauci is Senator
Rand Paul of Kentucky who many of you
will say that's Dr Rand Paul sir don't
forget that sir sure yeah but he is an
ophthalmologist
um and not an infectious disease
specialist and he is again tangling up
with Dr fauci Dr fauci seems to have
just had enough at one point telling uh
of Rand Paul that if anybody's lying
it's him which we will get to but first
saying that Rand Paul has no idea what
he's talking about let's look at let's
really look at this first exchange here
from yesterday's hearing and by the way
Rand Paul seems just obsessed with fauci
it's like Groundhog Day every single one
of these hearings with these two new
potential pandemic pathogens potential
pandemic pathogens that exist only in
the lab not in nature This research
matches these are Dr E Bright's words
this research matches indeed epitomizes
the definition of gain of function
research done entirely in Wuhan
for which there was supposed to be a
federal pause
Dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to Congress do you wish to retract
your statement of May 11. so already I
mean implying that that fauci has
perjured himself by lying you claimed
that the NIH never funded gain of
function research in Wuhan
microphone senator Paul I have never
lied before the Congress and I do not
retract that statement this paper that
you're referring to was judged by
qualified staff up and down the chain as
not being gain of function what was let
me finish Shake an animal virus and you
increase his responsibility to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct and and
senator Paul you do not know what you
are talking about quite frankly and I
want to say that officially you do not
know what you are talking about okay you
get one person's speech from the Nia can
I answer and it's not he's not even
allowed to fully answer the question
it's it's this Rand Paul is just some of
the worst of the worst of the American
political establishments function this
is your definition that you guys wrote
it says that scientific research that
increases the transmability about
transmissibility among animals is gain
of function they took animal viruses
that only occur in animals and they
increase their transmissibility to
humans how you can say that is not gain
a function it is not it's a dance and
you're dancing around this because
you're trying to obscure responsibility
for four million people dying around the
world from a pandemic and let's let's
send doctor it's funny because in other
contexts the pandemic isn't serious so
when it's convenient for Rand Paul to
say masks closures guidelines
restrictions this isn't nearly serious
enough and now he's saying this is so
serious Dr fauci that you're lying to us
well now you're getting into something
if the point that you are making is that
the the grant that was funded as a sub
award from Eco Health to Wuhan created
saws cov2 that's where you are getting
okay so again it's just endless us with
Rand Paul we've talked about the gain of
function stuff a number of times already
at the end of the day you could say this
could just come down to a sort of
semantic disagreement between entities
in terms of definitions of gain of
function but the obsession of Rand Paul
is what just cannot be understood here
let's look at a little more and here's
where fauci says if anybody here is
lying at you Rand Paul for four million
people dying around the world from a
pandemic and let's let's send doctor I
have to well now you're getting into
something if the point that you are
making is that the the Grant and there's
a little bit of overlap here for which I
apologize funded as a sub award from Eco
Health to Wuhan created sauce cov2
that's where you are getting let me
finish we don't know wait a minute I
come in the lab but all the evidence is
pointing that it came from the lab you
there will be responsibility for those
who funded the lab including yourself I
totally Rand Paul is blaming Dr fauci
for the pandemic it's crazy to allow the
witness to I totally resent the lie that
you are now propagating Senator because
if you look at the viruses that were
used in the experiments that were given
in the annual reports that were
published in the literature it is
molecularly impossible no one's saying
those it is positive it is
virus caused the pandemic what we're
alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab and
NIH funded it that is not away from it
it meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth I'm not
obfuscating the truth you're the one I'm
inspired but I will allow the witness to
let me just finish I want everyone to
understand that if you look at those
viruses and that's judged by qualified
virologists and evolutionary biologists
those viruses are molecularly impossible
results
we're saying they are gain of function
viruses because they're animal viruses
that became more transmissible in human
and you funded it and you commit the
truth and you imply you all your time
has expired and I will allow Witnesses
who come before this committee to
respond and you are implying that what
we did was responsible for the deaths of
individual I totally resent them and if
anybody is lying here Senator it is you
so this is just never ending never
ending and the you know the the world is
looking at how a doctor who has devoted
his life to trying to prevent pandemics
and communicable disease infectious
disease has become you know if not Enemy
Number One uh uh uh sort of co-enemy
number one to a particular political
contingent in the United States it's
humiliating and it's embarrassing and do
not expect this to stop anytime soon if
you want to see more about the gain of
function distinctions check out our
previous clip about this uh just go to
our Youtube channel search for uh
Anthony fauci Rand Paul and you will
find uh at least one maybe even a couple
of clips about it one of our sponsors
today is sheath underwear it's the
middle of summer that can mean a lot of
sweating sticking chafing with
traditional underwear but not with
sheath underwear which has created
unique boxer brief designs with multiple
ergonomic compartments in the front
keeps everything separate cool dry and
comfortable even in the hottest time of
year especially when you need it sheath
underwear was invented by an Iraq war
veteran who was looking for a solution
to the problems he was having with
traditional underwear in the desert heat
and he realized that what he came up
with is perfect for everyday use and
that's where sheath underwear came from
it keeps you dry and comfortable like no
other underwear can give sheath
underwear a try I've had a great
experience with it I know you will too
you can find the link right underneath
this video and don't forget to use the
promo code Pacman for 20 off